good morning he 23 so I've been trying
to think we need to give you some new
news something something new something
definitive but I'll be honest with you I
can't think of what to do right now so I
thought I'd bring a friend of mine out
who could together we'll decide what to
do ladies and gentlemen the co-writer
the director of the only Marvel Studios
film ever to be nominated for Best
Picture Ryan Coogler
[Applause]
[Applause]
we're afraid
now let's talk about a film that's
coming out in November of next year
about a group of immortals created by
Disney legend Jack Kirby and the film we
call the Eternals now this is we have
assembled a giant cast for you in this
this story spans thousands of years we
pull back the cosmic curtain on the MCU
in ways you can't imagine you want to
meet the eternal alright ladies and
gentlemen as Icarus Richard Madden
[Applause]
playing the eternal King go Kumail
Nanjiani
as the fastest eternal there is Macari
Lauren gridlock
[Applause]
we've got as fastest the amazing Brian
Tyree Henry let me introduce you to the
leader of the Eternals Ajax played by
Salma Hayek
and playing an eternal that is eternally
stuck at a 12 year old body even though
she's 7,000 years old liam ax cube as
sprite as the powerful Gilgamesh Donley
and as the warrior Athena Angelina Jolie
now I want to introduce you there's a
new eternal a new eternal named Rick
played by the great Barry Keough game
[Applause]
and believe it or not that's not all as
our final eternal Searcy we have Jemma
Chan
[Applause]
and I can also confirm playing a non
eternal character in this film named
Jane Whitman is mr. Kit Harington
[Applause]
this one is big our director Chloe's I
was in London getting ready to work but
I really wanted you to meet ladies and
gentlemen our Eternals
[Applause]
every generation has a legend
Star Wars is home to more than one and
I'm thrilled to invite a couple of them
to join me on the stage today
the first is someone we are so fortunate
to have as our Yoda of the Star Wars
today Kathy Kennedy president of
Lucasfilm and and producer of every Star
Wars film we've done it Disney powerful
she is please welcome and wait when we
have joining her filmmaker
extraordinaire and the writer director
of Star Wars the rise of Skywalker and
of course the force awakens JJ Abrams
Kathy and ginger
although one of the great experiences
that we had on this movie was of course
working with our incredible cast let's
meet them now
[Applause]
John boyega
[Applause]
Kelly Marie Tran
mr. Tom oh my oh me Aki
Keri Russell
[Applause]
and Billy Dee Williams
[Applause]
hello d23 was going on moving on or
should I say onward to the animation
studio since the first Toy Story the
brilliant minds at Pixar have delighted
audiences with amazing world's unique
characters and heartwarming stories the
conductor of the creative teams behind
these films is of course one of those
creatives himself he is the director of
Monsters Inc and up and inside out his
name is Pete docter and he's a great guy
is there a doctor in the house that
resists
please welcome Pete docter
[Applause]
[Music]
hey d23 Expo I'm Pete I have been up
here before as a filmmaker but not as
the chief creative officer of Pixar that
2020 is a very exciting time at Pixar
because we have two original films
coming out that's two original films and
now I'm directing a film that asks the
ultimate question that we've all thought
about at one time or another why am I
here
where did I come from and what am I here
for but I mean let's face it who would
make a cartoon about that I mean
metaphysics we're calling it soul
so to help me tell more about the film
please welcome some friends of mine
members of our sole creative team
producer Dana Marie Co director and
writer Kemp powers and writer Mike Jones
and now we would like to introduce you
to some of the amazing cast that are
bringing our characters to life first up
we want to bring out the drummer from
the jazz band you saw in the earlier
clip the character's name is curly he
will be voiced by Questlove from the
roots gentlemen
Questlove how you doing all right next
up we have Jose loving mother Libba and
she'll be voiced by the great Felicia
Rashad please welcome
hi d23 hello we're also gonna meet Joe's
neighborhood nemesis Paul he's gonna be
voiced by the amazing daveed Diggs
from ABC's blackish and of course the
Broadway hit Hamilton to V Diggs
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
what's up guys as if these guys aren't
amazing enough we would like to
introduce you to the voices of Joe
Gardner and 22 ladies and gentlemen
please give a d23 welcome to Jamie Foxx
and Tina Fey
[Applause]
let's move onward to onward ladies and
gentlemen please welcome producer Corey
Ray and director Dan Scanlon
[Applause]
this movie takes place in a modern
fantasy world and it tells the story of
two elf brothers named Ian and barley
Lightfoot ian is an awkward teenager
he's smart and thoughtful but she's shy
and lacks confidence and then barley his
older brother has like way too much
confidence barley is chaotic and wild
and his lives his life in the past
really really really far in the past he
longs for the days of magic and quests
as you can see these two brothers are
quite different from each other
barley tends to cause Ian more trouble
than good and while Ian loves his
brother he doesn't wanna be like him
and Ian has he's a little short on role
models because his father passed away
before Ian was born more than anything
in the world
Ian wishes he had just one chance to
meet his dad please welcome to the stage
Tom Holland and Chris Pratt
[Applause]
[Music]
Wow what's up everybody
elf buddies and brothers need a mom so
we have another very important character
in this film the boy's mother Laura
Lightfoot we're extremely excited that
Laura will be voiced by the one and only
Julia louis-dreyfus Julia d23
oh wow
from a wild carpet ride to a wild river
ride we have gone deep into the jungles
to find the inspiration for one of our
next big adventures in fact we've gone
all the way to the backside of water in
Jungle Cruise Thank You of course as you
know Jungle Cruise takes its cue from
the beloved parks attraction but like
Pirates of the Caribbean it will sail
into a world all of its own on the big
screen Frank is the charismatic skipper
of a dubious looking riverboat called
lukela from which he runs a sightseeing
business that may or may not be totally
aboveboard Frank is approached by a
determined scientist and Explorer dr.
Lily Houghton who hires him to take her
downriver on a dangerous mission of
course since they're polar opposites
this sets the stage for a freewheeling
adventure filled with unexpected twists
over-the-top comedy and most of all star
power ladies and gentlemen Johnson and
Emily boy
Maleficent mistress of evil is the
follow-up to 2014 s Maleficent which
explored the motivations behind one of
the greatest disney villains of all time
director Yocum roaning of pirates of the
caribbean dead men tell no tales bring
them at brings the magical Moors to life
as we delve deeper into this rich world
of which we've barely scratched the
surface we are obviously so thrilled to
have the singular and magnificent
Angelina Jolie back again as Maleficent
so please welcome back to the stage our
eternal leading lady Angelina Jolie
the relationship between Maleficent and
Aurora played once again by Elle Fanning
is complicated by Philips mother Queen
Ingrid played by the amazing Michelle
Pfeiffer in this movie we also learn
more about Maleficent's brethren the
Dark Fae led by Chu Attell Ejiofor in
the film so Angie how does all of this
change the dynamic I would never want to
speak for them so I think they should
speak for themselves
ladies and gentlemen Elle Fanning
Michelle Pfeiffer and Chiwetel Ejiofor
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and now from one epic tale to another in
March we will bring Mulan to the screen
thank you in a spectacular new
live-action telling the drawers from
both the revered source material and
Disney's classic animated interpretation
Mulan story plays against a backdrop of
immense scope and scale shot against the
stunning backdrops of China and New
Zealand we brought in hundreds upon
hundreds of background actors to bring
these spectacular battle scenes to life
yet the legend of this great warrior is
also a deeply human story of a young
woman discovering her true power and we
have found the perfect director to tell
this intimate character drama on a grand
scale in Niki Caro
as we have explored some of these
well-known classic stories from
different perspectives we've done only
one that centers around the backstory of
one of Disney's so-called great villains
with Maleficent that will change soon
with Cruella as we know her she truly
lives up to her name but how did she get
that way and what made Cruella so cruel
director Craig Gillespie and two
fabulous Emma's Emma Stone and Emma
Thompson will take us back to the early
days of this notorious and notoriously
fashionable diva Disney Animation as you
well know is the cornerstone of our
company and it's where it all began and
with chief creative officer Jennifer Lee
at the helm
so they the Disney animation team
continues to make amazing films that
resonate around the world Jen herself is
an amazing writer and director as you
know with frozen and wreck-it Ralph
among her credits so Jen chief creative
officer the stage is yours today as a
d23 exclusive I get to talk about next
year's feature film from Disney
Animation coming out Thanksgiving 2020
it's from the incredible directors Paul
Briggs and Dean Williams who are master
story artists who worked on some of the
most poignant moments big hero six
frozen The Princess and the Frog in
beautopia just to name a few
it's also our producer is not sure which
you may know from Moana she brought that
to the screen and our incredible
screenwriter Adele Lim who most recently
wrote that little story you might have
heard of called crazy rich Asians so
we're here to tell you about Raya and
the Last Dragon please welcome Dean
Paulo's not an Adele
[Music]
play the voice of our dragon is the star
of crazy rich Asians and the farewell
I'm thrilled to team up once again with
the one the only
Aquafina please welcome Cassie Steele
and Aquafina
[Applause]
there's one more film we'd like to talk
about today it's a little labor of love
for us that's coming out this November
22nd in theaters in 2012 legendary
animator and director Chris Buck invited
me to join as writer and soon after
director with him on a project inspired
by The Snow Queen please welcome my
mentor collaborator and partner fellow
director Chris buck
[Applause]
all right I was afraid of make a thing
we are excited to announce that voicing
on an else's mother is star of West
world Evan Rachel Wood we also mentioned
that our gang ventures to an enchanted
forest and there they encounter
lieutenant Matias who leads a group of
soldiers who have been trapped in that
forest since a fierce battle broke out
over 30 years ago voicing lieutenant
Matias is none other than Emmy and
Golden Globe winning star this is us in
black panther sterling T Brown so ladies
and gentlemen please give a warm welcome
to every racial wood and sterling K
Brown
[Applause]
[Music]
so as we said in frozen to our gang
confronts change and in the end nothing
will ever be the same
but luckily some things never change
like our incredible original casts for
frozen one back for frozen - ladies and
gentlemen jonathan groff idina menzel
kristen
thank you guys thank you thank you Thank
You d23 thank you so much thank you
everybody have a wonderful Expo we thank
you so much hope you enjoyed the show